So the latest update I have as of this moment
and to not talk about it would be weird, but
I have to acknowledge that things are moving
very quickly and we may have different news
by the time you listen to today's show.
The news is that Donald Trump may be going
home soon.
Today, he may already be home or maybe not.
He still is scheduled to have a rally tonight,
which is just completely inconceivable.
Obviously, if he did it, it would be some
kind of remote thing.
He would be joining me via remote video.
Donald Trump, of course, is is not traveling
to a rally tonight, but he's either doing
well or not doing well.
We just don't know.
We are left to try to infer and to try to
wade through the lies.
But one thing we have in black and white is
that this morning Donald Trump sent 20, 20
consecutive completely manic tweets in a very
short period of time from the hospital, almost
all in capital letters.
And once again, this could be anything.
Is Trump tweeting because he's panicked that
the latest polls are really bad?
Is he simply manic from the dexamethasone?
Kordic corticosteroid induced mania is not
an uncommon side effect of dexamethasone and
other steroids.
We just don't know.
But the tweets are completely outrageous.
Take a look at just some of these.
As you can see here, Donald Trump tweeting,
Most of these are all caps.
Stock market highs vote.
Virginia voters, your governor wants to obliterate
your Second Amendment.
I have stopped him.
If you want a massive tax increase, the biggest
in the history of our country and one that
will shut our economy and jobs down.
Vote Democrat.
I'm voting for Donald Trump.
My father is a union worker and his four one
K has tripled under President Trump.
Obviously, the stock market hasn't tripled.
So if the four on K has tripled, maybe the
person started contributing three times as
much, sort of a non sequitur than just another
string of all caps, tweets, pro-life vote,
massive regulation cuts vote space force vote.
Best V.A ever, 91 percent approval rating.
Vote for a one K vote.
Biggest tax cut ever.
And another one coming.
Vote.
Religious liberty.
Both law and order.
Vote.
Peace through strength.
Save our Second Amendment.
Vote.
Fight the corrupt fake news media.
Protect preexisting conditions.
Vote better and cheaper health care.
Vote so completely out of control.
Could this be a combination of a steroid add
up? Trump seeing the latest NBC poll, which
has him down by 14 points to Joe Biden and
simply doing what he feels he can do from
a hospital.
Our friend Faren Cousins from Ring of Fire
wrote to me on Twitter, Most likely it's the
steroids.
I've been on them before for severe asthma
and they can make you very angry and aggressive.
Has someone again lost control of Trump?
It is all speculation brought on by the reality
that Trump's behavior doesn't make any sense
and his doctors aren't.
We aren't being honest.
And this administration hasn't been honest
about Trump's health since day one.
And Trump lies about everything.
Dexamethasone, rare side effect of the drug
includes grandiose delusions.
How would you be able to tell the difference
with this guy?
And some experts have expressed concern about
the combinations of things Trump has gotten,
as you now know.
Trump received an unapproved antibody cocktail
rham deaths severe and dexamethasone at minimum
that we know of.
Dr. Thomas McGinn from the New York state
health provider Northwest Health said to The
New York Times that the kitchen sink is being
thrown at Donald Trump.
And Dr. Vin Gupta said, you don't start dexamethasone
rham death severe and an antibody treatment
that is yet unapproved.
If the president just slightly has a lower
oxygen level, you do it when there's Cauvin
pneumonia or something more serious.
Will we ever know the truth?
I really don't know.
We certainly don't know it right now.
And we've certainly never gotten the truth
on a whole bunch of other things that have
happened during the last four years.
So we may never know.
Next, we are going to talk about more overt
doctoring of the tapes, as the case may be